well we've just heard some exciting news
about our very own professor Polyakov
he's going to become the foreign
secretary of the Royal Society now if
you're anything like me you probably
don't know what that means
so I've asked three people to help
explain first professor Polyakov himself
also professor Lawrence Yves you might
recognize him from some of our sixty
symbols videos actually and lastly
another familiar face dr. pate license
he's worked here in Nottingham alongside
professor Polyakov for the last 11 years
the Royal Society is one of the oldest
if not the oldest academies of Science
in the world it was started in 1660 by a
group of scientists and it was sponsored
by king charles ii in america the
akattak corresponding organizations
called the National Academy of Sciences
which is very well known the interesting
thing about the the Royal Society of
London to give its formal name is that
it does involve countries like India and
Canada and New Zealand Australia South
Africa and so on so it's it's a truly
international fellowship because of this
Commonwealth connection it's like the
elite you know you have to be invited or
you are elected to the Royal Society and
you're elected by the fellows of that
society so this really is peer
recognition in its best in its ultimate
form now I'm I said I'd really give my
eyeteeth to to become a fellow or a
member of that Academy or the Royal
Society I am fortunate to have been a
fellow of the Royal Society since 2002
and each year there are 44 scientists
and mathematicians in the UK all the
British Commonwealth who are elected
certainly people are very pleased when
they're elected I think it was a wiener
what are the big bombers in my my life
when I was elected
yeah well Martin he's been a fellow in
the raw Society for a number of years
now and him and we all thought that that
was probably the pinnacle you know being
elected to become an FRS really is a big
thing but the Royal Society of
she I suppose recognized Martin even
further
we've just been a press release saying
that Martin Polyakov will become the new
foreign secretary now that's not the
foreign secretary of the of the UK
government it's for a secular society
there still has to be an election but
all being well I will become the next
foreign secretary starting on the
evening of the 30th of November why are
you so confident of winning this
election
well because of strange traditions I'm
the only candidate so you got a pretty
good chance I hope so but people can
still object I think I feel unwell I
feel very excited and quite humbled the
difference from getting a medal or an
award is that with a medal or award you
are just expected to give a lecture or a
few lectures or whatever this is much
more of a job and that I have to
actually do things and it will give me a
chance I hope to help younger scientists
in the UK and across the world and to
communicate my enthusiasm for science to
other people the job of the Foreign
Secretary is to lead the Royal Society
he's the lead role in the Royal Society
for making sure that the Royal Society
and science in the UK is recognized and
promoted internationally and also he's
the other important aspect of his job I
believe is that he interacts with the
other academies around the world so the
Russian Academy the National Academy of
Sciences in the u.s. in particular and
we have strong links with and he is
forging links and collaborations and is
generally helping to promote
collaborations between UK scientists and
other scientists around the world it's
it's a fantastic mark of achievement for
Martin we're all incredibly proud of him
and we're all we wish him the best of
luck in the position and hope that well
he can even go forward and make changes
to science on the global scale I will
continue doing some of my job but very
generously the University has agreed
that I can spend some
with the Royal Society exactly how much
of my time I don't know but I am very
keen to continue doing research and as
far as possible I also want to do some
teaching it's supposed to be one of
these part-time jobs I think two days a
week but the vice-president's that I've
met have told me it's it's more more
like three days a week and sometimes
it's a five day a week job as the name
of his position implies the the foreign
secretary I think he may have to travel
quite a lot it's a great opportunity for
Martin and it really is an opportunity
for all of our staff actually for one of
our for one of our faculty to take this
position really is an honour for us all
not just for Martin or not an honor for
us and the university what about
periodic table of videos we used to
seeing you almost every week on YouTube
does that mean we're not going to see
you so much anymore no the periodic
table of videos is a big priority and I
very keen to pursue it and in fact the
Royal Society's press release mentions
it so this will definitely continue